do you think it's easier to be an
independent filmmaker in America rather
than India oh it's very easy to be a
independent filmmaker in India because
all are very few studios that operate
they've come from the West one or two
Indian companies are doing it thick they
are studios the rest are all independent
films it's very easy to be an
independent produce I am an independent
producer not reliant on any studio
facilities but think when things go
wrong it goes drastically wrong for an
independent filmmaker what do you think
the perception is of independent
filmmakers in the States vs india sounds
like it's more revered in india because
there's so many yeah i know that's the
only way we would rather that we had
somebody taking all the risk for us we
are taking it all ourselves this some of
the phones don't even have insurance
things go wrong they go down it's like
bungee jumping and we try to check the
cards but it can never be sure it just
seems like there's almost a stigma
sometimes in the United States with
being an independent filmmaker that
somehow people feel that the audience is
not there unless you've been given that
sundance premiere what would you say
that's why sundance that have happened i
think more such things I mean the dth
revolution might change some of that
that's why act champion it in a big way
because it's its access to audience
internet internet was like that but if
you can monetize physically monetize I
think deed yet can do it and that's why
I look at it as an opportunity not just
for myself for me it's an allied
monetizing venue another window but for
a filmmaker who wants to be independent
different and intelligent not play all
the time by one rule he has a great for
me it's a window
for him it's an open field do you think
independent filmmakers are not as
collaborative as they could be and that
holds them back maybe they're the lone
wolf the rebel that that can't do it in
the group way that you talked about is
necessary to complete a project you
think that hurts them they're
independent oh yes yes it hurts me
because I I bet all the money I have
most of the time if the film doesn't do
I start from scratch again I've done it
a couple of times I don't enjoy it very
much and you're able to sleep at night
oh yes because to begin with I never had
this money everything else was bonus so
I can't complain
you